BY SUICIDE IN 2020.
AMERICAN COUNTRY AND SOUTHERN
GOSPEL SINGER AND SONGWRITER
LARRY CATLIN THE KING OF ROCK
'N' ROLL IN LISA'S FATHER ELVIS
JOINS ME NOW.
THIS IS SO SAD TO HAVE HEARD
THIS REACTION TONIGHT.
>> IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU I WISH
IT WERE UNDER DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I WAS SHOCKED AT 74 YEARS OLD I
THINK I'D PROBABLY INCORPORATED
THESE DAYS IN WHICH I LIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT DEATH.
THEN I DID WHEN I WAS 54 OR 3424
.
WE WERE TOLD CHRISTIAN PEOPLE
SAY WELL YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
QUESTION GOD.
I THINK IT'S MALARKEY.
WE WOULD NOT BE HUMAN BEINGS IF
WE DID NOT QUESTION THINGS
HAPPEN TO YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE LIS
MARIE OR THE YOUNG MAN WHO
ALMOST DIED THE OTHER DAY FIX T
THE GRACE OF GOD THE PARAMEDICS
BROUGHT HIM BACK TO LIFE.
AND VERY SADDENED BY IT.
THEIR FAMILY HAS SO MUCH TRAGED
IN THAT FAMILY ONE OF MY COUSIN
BELIEVE IT OR NOT JOHN BOWEN WH
WROTE NO MAN IS AN ISLAND UNTO
HIMSELF WE ARE ALL PART OF
CIVILIZATION AND WHEN ANY PERSO
DIES IT AFFECTS ME BECAUSE I AM
PART OF THE MAIN I AM PART OF
CIVILIZATION PART OF COMMUNITY.
WHEN OUR FELLOW MAN TRAGEDY
STRIKES LIKE THIS, OBVIOUSLY IT
BREAKS OUR HEARTS.
>> ELVIS AS EVERYTHING I'VE REA
IN THE BIOGRAPHIES OF ELVIS THA
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO READ OVER THE
LAST 25 YEARS.
HE LOVED HIS DAUGHTER SO MUCH.
HIS ONLY CHILD AND SHE HAD
OBVIOUSLY UNDERSTAND HER
FATHER'S DRUG USE HER SON
STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION AND
COMMITTED SUICIDE WAS WELL
DOCUMENTED HER OWN STINTS IN
REHAB AND STRUGGLES WITH COCAIN
AND OTHER DRUGS WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THE CAUSE OF DEATH WAS
ULTIMATE DEATH OTHER THAN
CARDIAC ARREST WHAT CAUSED THAT
CARDIAC ARREST THIS IS REALLY A
SERIES OBVIOUSLY MICHAEL JACKSO
DYING AFTER THE USE OF PROPOFOL
THIS IS A SERIES OF TRAGIC
EVENTS.
>> IT REALLY IS I'VE BEEN
NASHVILLE FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS
WE HAVE SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAI
THE CHILDREN OF FAMOUS PEOPLE T
HAVE A TOUGH ROAD.
BUT ALL OF US WHO AMONG US THOS
PEOPLE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
TRYING TO BUY BREAD AND MILK AN
DIAPERS FOR THEIR KIDS.
WE'RE KIND OF NEJM AS A WORLD.
AS A COUNTRY.
IT IS TIME FOR US TO A CIRCLE
AROUND AND HUG EACH OTHER PRAY
FOR EACH OTHER.
NOTHING WE CAN SAY THAT WOULD
MAKE THEM FEEL ANY BETTER BUT W
SAY IT ANYWAY BECAUSE OUR HEART
HAVE COMPASSION.
I KNEW LISA MARIE A LITTLE BIT
BABYSAT WITH HER MANY YEARS AGO
WHEN HER MOM WAS GOOD FRIENDS
WITH SKU A FRIEND OF OURS WE
WERE IN VEGAS SHE WAS JUST A
BABY AND INFANT THE FEW TIMES I
MET HER SHE CAME TO THE GRAND
OLD OPRY SHE WAS VERY SWEET.
I LOVED AND RESPECTED HER FATHE
AND THINK ONE OF THE TRAGIC IT'
A TRAGIC WHEN ANYONE PASSES AWA
BUT ESPECIALLY IN THE PRIME OF
LIFE.
THE CATLIN'S ARE PLAYING FOR TH
PRESLEY'S AND WISHING PEACE AND
COMFORT COME TO THEM.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT SO MANY
TALENTED MUSICIANS OBVIOUSLY
THERE FAMOUS PEOPLE MICHAEL
JACKSON, PRINCE OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN THI
CASE BUT SO MANY OVER THE YEARS
SO MANY HAVE PASSED AWAY WHITNE
HOUSTON THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
OF PEOPLE OF ENORMOUS TALENT.
>> A LOT OF TIMES IT'S HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO TELIS NO HOW TO GET
TELL ELVIS PRESLEY TOO STOP
DOING THAT PEOPLE TOLD ME TO
STOP DOING IT UP BY THE GRACE O
THE MERCIFUL GOD WHEN JANICE AN
COACH DARRELL CAME TO ME AND
SAID YOU HAVE TO STOP ACTING
LIKE THAT IS HIS BOOK PAGE 157
THINK MY STORY IT'S HARD.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
IT'S HARD TO DO THAT.
THEY GOT FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO D
AND FIGURE FOLKS OUT THERE IN
RADIO AND TV LAND IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE IN YOUR LIFE HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THAT, GO TAKE A
HOLD OF THEM BY THE NECK AND BY
THE HEART AND TELL HIM THEY NEE
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I'M GRATEFUL TO GOD THAT DARREL
JANICE DID IT FOR